oh no um from uh someone who's
supporting rishi sunak a friend of the
program minister for care and mental
health julian keegan hi it's great to
see you thanks for joining us we've
missed your smiling face i wonder how
much um she's seen as smiling this
morning didn't do as well as he expected
a quarter of the parliamentary party
when you've got eight candidates
that's pretty good i think that my math
says that's pretty good okay but penny
morden's um probably cock-a-hoop this
morning i'm sure penny is really pleased
with her result yeah why do you think
she's done so well um
i don't know actually i don't know penny
so well um i don't really know penny so
well but you know i still think it's
very clear that mishi has a very strong
following he's got a lot of support he's
got a lot of support of lots of
different people actually north south
brexiteers remainers
lots of different seats he's even got
the support of most of the former
chancellors so there's a lot of support
for rishi
where do the next votes come from though
because it looks as though the other
candidates are more to the right so once
they fall in behind potentially i don't
know liz truss um or then it's becoming
much more complicated for you it's
complicated anyway because if you even
look at the mix of people you know
people people are not forming into the
same camps that you could have seen you
know maybe in last elections there's
definitely people who've got very
different views um you know certainly on
brexit but also on other issues who are
actually joining together and i think
that's because i mean certainly in the
case of rishi i think what we all
recognize is
the experience he has and the experience
we need these are serious times where in
serious times need serious people and i
think that's probably why he's building
quite a wide coalition you say that but
um there's been some disastrous polling
for him from uh yugo of polar party
members um and it looks as well
definitely as far as they were concerned
with their party member polling more
than 67 soon at 28
so our our party members are pretty
open-minded and they're going to go
through a process where there's five
hustings all over the country and they
will be put through the mill through the
test that actually is the process that
counts it's the only process that counts
and you know there isn't
a single issue like there was last time
they will really put them through and
they'll get to know them better as a
single issue isn't there it's the cost
of living well the single issue is who
can navigate us through the cost of
living and grow our economy absolutely
who can tackle inflation tackle the cost
of living grow our economy and then cut
taxes is is the is the is the approach
that uh rishi's taking yeah but they
know all of that i mean they're not
stupid you're members are they and 67
percent of them think penny morton well
it's a poll okay there's many many polls
as you know and and actually a lot of
the polls at this point you know you you
you can take a little with a pinch of
salt when they get to know the
candidates when they they don't know all
the candidates very well i mean we don't
know who the final two will be but some
of them you know are not as well known
um when they go through those hustins
five times all over the country the
members will then
make make a decision they know they're
making a serious decision they know
they're making a decision about who will
lead the country and actually one of the
most influential countries in the world
during very challenging times um both at
home and abroad with global inflation
and with the euro war in ukraine they
know the size and the magnitude of this
decision oh rishi soon access he'll run
the economy like margaret thatcher
that's not even close though is it what
do you mean well i mean that uh in march
richie sunak said he would raise the
uk's tax burden to it um to its highest
level in 70 years um maggie thatcher was
never you you make sure you make your
decisions based on the times that you're
in i think that's why all the former
chancellors have said we back russia's
plan rishi's plan and we think margaret
thatcher would as well because obviously
she didn't have to deal with a pandemic
obviously we didn't have exactly the
same situation in terms of a war in
ukraine obviously there was the falcons
wall but that was a long uh further away
so every your times are your times you
get the hand that you're dealt with
can't say that you're gonna run the
economy like margaret thatcher then can
you i mean sensibly is what you mean
sensibly so
what are you saying don't you
corporation taxed from 52 to 34 income
tax from i've got the figures in front
of me 33 to 25 percent wishing that
plans to raise corporation tax from 19
to 25 percent and no immediate impact on
time what were the numbers that you
mentioned for margaret thatcher from 52
to
52 to 34. yeah and today it's 19.
yeah
it's a totally different situation it's
not just whether it goes wrong put them
up there doesn't it yes yes that well
that's that's the current plan so that's
going the opposite direction yeah but
it's not about where the arrow points
it's actually the it is it's actually
the rate and how it compares to other
countries as well and that's that's
that's quite an important point because
what you're doing with your corporation
tax is trying to attract inward business
investment which we are still a very
popular destination for for for foreign
direct investment and for business
investment and he's been very innovative
about some of the business investment
focuses he's got with the super deductor
with free ports et cetera it's a very
you know you do what your time it
requires okay um and and i think i think
he is very determined to cut taxes we're
all determined to cut taxes we're
conservatives but you've got to do it
after you've tackled inflation you're
saying
you've brought it under control what
inflation is going down and not after as
soon as it starts to fall
well i don't that will be a decision for
him but yes it when you get to the point
where you think you've got inflation
under control if you do it the other way
around do you risk your manifesto you
have to know so you risk if you do when
you say information brought under
control is it as soon as it starts to
fall is it when you feel that it's
plateaued when is it
i think there'll be a number of views in
terms of the economist views but it's
when we feel confident that tattling
that the inflation these inflationary
risers are caused by shortage of supply
posts a pandemic and the whole supply
chain is being disrupted plus the war in
ukraine you know if the war in ukraine
ended in three months time it would
change the picture if if it doesn't and
it goes on and you know we've also got
the questions of what happens with gray
and et cetera so there's a lot of very
complex things so it's
we will cut taxes as soon as we possibly
can based on what you said is when
inflation is under as soon as we
possibly can once inflation's under
control if you there's no point in in in
raise if if you really don't know when
that's if you raise taxes which then
fuel inflation which then also raise
interest rates you may have more money
in your pocket but you've got to spend a
lot more there's no point it doesn't
that's when you get into the well
she plans to borrow in order to pay for
tax cuts um and she says that that will
spare extra growth well our borrowing
costs right now are about 83 billion
pounds a year that is you know more than
we spend way more than we spend on
defense even during these times so if
you want to
increase that by more then you know
that's i think that's dead money so i
don't personally um you know i want to
see that come down as much as possible
but we can't you know we can't ignore
the fact we've been through a pandemic
okay the fellow scheme and all the other
schemes were cost a lot of money but
they did protect people's jobs and they
did protect the businesses in our
country why didn't you resign
um well because i'm the social care and
mental health minister and you know the
so important to everything that i'm
doing the massive reforms we know that
we have to build our mental health
services to get the capacity we know we
have to reform social care to take that
pressure off the nhs and also make sure
we've got much better social care so you
didn't understand because your job's
important
yes and i knew what i had to do kate i
knew all the things i had to do the
first meeting on thursday was with the
new ics chairs i knew what i had to do
because your job's important did richie
not not think that his job was important
no everyone has their own equation and
he you know he he'd obviously been
closer and had these conversations with
uh
the prime minister's design then given
no no not at all some people resigned
and actually my colleagues you have to
make it's a really hard decision if you
resign
you know that that's one thing and i
know many colleagues are really sad that
they're not able to do the jobs but they
just felt they had to do this to to to
you know to create uh what's it to to
get rid of the last prime minister or
the current prime minister but in my
case the balance um or that i took was
you know you've got to get a balance
you've got to have some people running
the country as well so yeah but how much
more i mean the most important job in
the country after the prime minister
is the chancellor of the exchequer
especially during a crisis that could
see us heading towards recession yeah
and because he wants the top job he
decided selfishly some might say to to
resign when we were right in the middle
of it and i'm guessing that uh
grassroots members who will be voting
who the next prime minister is will see
him as a judas i don't think so i think
it depends on your your view of of the
former prime minister or the current
prime minister you know some people will
feel that but some people will feel you
know we had
um the the chris pincher episode was
just the straw that broke the camel's
back you know these we spent all of our
time when there are serious things and
i've been on this show many times
wanting to talk about mental health or
social care and we've talked about you
know parties or um you know other
people's behavior which is is not what
we need to be talking about we have to
run the country we have to do it well
who do you think are going to be in the
final two i don't know um but i think i
i i i hope rishi is is in the final two
i mean you know now everyone's going to
be working very hard for votes it can
move around quite quickly i hope he is
in in the final two but we do have a
fantastic range of candidates and i must
say i am really proud when i open that
paper and see them all it is amazing
right that's a really i'm proud of ours
are you speaking to your guy every day
at the moment yes okay will he come on
and do our debate next week i don't know
but i'll ask him for you okay yeah
should he
um i don't i don't know anything about
your debate i don't know when it's
happening or next week it's on monday um
i know there's a vote on monday but you
know it gives them the opportunity to
speak directly not just to other
candidates but to also another member
mps but also to the grassroots i am sure
we've got a ver we've got 100 people in
the audience oh right okay i am sure
everybody will want to i mean you know
the the country quite rightly will want
to ask questions as well it's not just
about us and then the conservative
members so there will be i'm sure a lot
of engagement he's very open i think he
has a great style actually he's very um
even my taxi driver was saying that this
morning so is that yes
i can't answer for him i'm not his media
um person but i will tell him that you
would love him to come on fantastic i'll
put a word in for you i'm sure our
viewers will as well you're very kind
thank you julian keegan thanks very much
indeed